cookie poursuivre sa stratégie de
l'encerclement baptiste falgos bon
jouant des faits de temps ensemble ce
qui est en train de se jouer toujours
sur le terrain ce front sud qui reste
évidemment l'un des principaux fronts
stratégiques pour pour les re si on le
voit bien c'est là-bas au cycle
offensive est la plus virulente un peu
virulente et là où la catastrophe
humanitaire et la pire on va voir ses
villes sur la carte justement avec mario
paul d'abord où le bilan humain ne cesse
de s'alourdir mario paul vous voyez
voilà derrière moi qui ai donc un
dernier point qui permettrait si elle
est conquise de contrôler toute la mer
d'azov par les russes mario paul qui si
elle est prise également permettrait aux
troupes russes venant de crime est de
faire la jonction avec celles venant du
dombass à ce niveau-là et marioupol
effectivement la catastrophe et c'était
épouvantable on est à 2500 morts
attention c'est le bilan donné par les
autorités ukrainiennes à prendre avec
prudence mais c'est là où les combats
sont peut-être les plus virulents
effectivement autre ville autre ville
cette fois qui est près de la mer noire
c'est mikolaj fait on vient de le voir
d'ailleurs dans ce reportage de
gwendoline vide assiégé les russes s'ils
prennent cette ville pour ont foncé
directement vers odessa ce porc
hautement symbolique d'un point de vue
aussi historique pour la russie et
contrôler la mer noire mais une partie
de la mer noire en tout cas et c'était
intéressant dans le reportage de
gwendoline puisqu'elle montrait que les
troupes russes en plus de pilonner la
ville tant de la contourner par le nord
mais ils font face on l'a vu à une
résistance acharnée de la part des
troupes d'ukrainiens en ce qui concerne
la mer noire on notera que même si la
russie pour l'instant ne contrôle pas
donc la façade de la mer noire en tout
cas dans son intégralité elle la
contrôler defacto puisque les navires
russes sont disposés de façon à bloquer
tout échange venant provenance ou à
destination des côtes de la mer noire
c'est en tout cas ce qu'a annoncé tout à
l'heure le ministère de la défense
britannique alors sur le front
diplomatique peut être maintenant une
nouvelle phase de négociation a lieu
aujourd'hui des responsables et les deux
parties discutent par visioconférence
après l'échec on vous le rappelle les
trois premières sessions de pourparlers
en biélorussie et puis la rencontre
jeudi dernier en turquie entre les chefs
de diplomaties russe et ukrainien la
donne pourrait être dit-on différente
aujourd'hui il semblerait qu'il y ait du
mieux 1 depuis ce week end ces dernières
heures les deux camps ont fait état
d'avancées dans les discussions on va
écouter tout de suite le président
volodymyr sienne qui avant de reparler
avec vous baptiste
shenzhen les représentants des
délégations de nos pays par le temps
visioconférence tous les jours notre
délégation un objectif clair faire en
sorte d'organiser une réunion entre les
présidents une réunion qui est j'en suis
sûr attendu par nous peuple bien sûr
c'est difficile à mettre en place c'est
beaucoup demander mais c'est nécessaire
à l'échelle aires protégées voilà voilà
pour la partie ukrainienne y compris les
russes font état de progrès
significatifs baptiste et il semblerait
qu'il y ait du mieux à quel point c'est
un peu la question qu'on se pose
aujourd'hui jusqu'où ça peut aller oui
alors il faut noter une chose d'abord le
dialogue n'a jamais été rompu on a
beaucoup parlé des discussions
pourraient peut-être devoir d'ailleurs à
l'image les discussions et les
négociateurs ukrainiens notamment
mihailo pownall ya qu'on voit ce film
est dans la rue on le voyait à l'instant
sur les images voilà ici assez
médiatique le dialogue n'a jamais été
rompu on a parlé des rencontres en
physique mais en fait ils continuent de
se parler quasiment quotidiennement par
visioconférence c'est d'ailleurs le cas
encore aujourd'hui ce négociateur mirent
à oman miraelaw peau de yack pardon a
expliqué hier que la russie avait je
cite cessé de lancer des ultimatums à
kiev et commencer à garat écouter
activement les propositions ukrainienne
s'agit-il de progrès sur des détails de
cessez le feu provisoire ou vraiment sur
le fond du dossier alors là c'est
impossible à dire pour le moment là
l'avancé principal elle a été faite en
fait la semaine dernière lorsque le
président volodymyr zelensky a dit qu'il
était prêt à ne plus insister pour que
son pays adhère à l'otan c'est une
avancée considérable
il s'est dit également prêt à des
négociations sur le dombass et les
territoires contestés du nom basse et
dans la foulée vous avez la russie qui
avait affirmé qu'elle ne visait pas un
changement de régime en ukraine voilà
donc s'agit-il de discussions qui vont
partir sur ses bases ou s'agit-il pour
la russie tout simplement de gagner du
temps pour mener à bien sa guerre pour
l'instant c'est vraiment très difficile
de le prévoir en tout cas les ukrainiens
ont réitéré 1 ce matin leur leur
position leur requête une demande
immédiate d'un cessez-le-feu un retrait
aussi des troupes russes du pays on
verra
ce que donnent ces nouveaux échanges du
jour merci beaucoup baptiste voilà ce
que l'on pouvait dire de cette guerre en
ukraine